[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so you know one of the questions that I
tend to get quite a lot is as a
professional programmer how do I write
code what do I do when I don't know what
code to write do I use Google do I use
Stack Overflow am I just that smart that
I can just kind of do it from memory
without even having to Google or
anything is what is life like as a
professional program well let them talk
about that today because it seems to be
something that a lot of people are
confused about and I'm just going to
talk about my experiences as a software
engineer working on core technology FDA
and how I kind of write code and how I
use the internet or other references
kind of facilitate that let's just get
right on it so first of all yes I mean
I'm pretty sure every programmer on the
planet writes code with the internet I
mean it's very difficult to actually
write code without having anything to
refer to now like
to be concise with my answer what I
would say is that in depends on what I'm
riding if I'm riding something kind of
simple like okay let's just talk about
game programming and like game engine
development because that's what I do
professionally if I'm running something
that I've written before like let's just
say maybe a toonie batch renderer or
something similar I don't really need to
hook that up because I've done it before
and I've done it enough times that I
know how that how'd that how that actual
component is architecture I know how to
actually write that code I've done it
before I might want to investigate
different ways of doing it in the case
that maybe I have a different idea or
I'm on a different platform that I've
never worked on but for the most part
like I don't really need to consult a
reference for that because I know what
I'm doing and I've done it before
and generally I tend to remember things
pretty well but if it's something fairly
complicated like maybe a physically
based rendering like shader or something
like that I can't write a PBR shader
from memory like that's like thousand
lines of like maths equations like I
can't do that even though I have done it
before I can't just do that from memory
so of course I'm gonna be googling for
references or maybe on github looking
for a source code or maybe like awesome
questions on Stack Overflow I don't do
that that often but those kinds of
things of course I'm gonna do things
like that because I am human and I can't
just remember everything that comes
but but I will say that there are things
of course that I do not and me
personally like I'm kind of a big
believer and the fact that you should be
memorizing the code that you're writing
like not specifically trying to memorize
it but there's no reason for you to not
know any code or not be able to write
something on paper I'm fairly confident
that I could write an entire game engine
in a game on paper and it would probably
kind of mostly compile
right like not saying huge complicated
systems but in general I should feel I
should be I am confident enough that I
am competent and actually writing
something down on paper without looking
at any reference is kind of like what
you might do in an exam but when it does
come to complicated things I may be
looking up API things I would definitely
be consulting the Internet so don't be
afraid if you're if you find yourself
googling constantly especially if you're
just learning programming as well like
it's fine if you're if you've been
programming for years but if you're kind
of new to it or you're new to OpenGL for
example and you're you find yourself
doing a lot of course even at Google
stuff like that's normal people do that
when I when I when I'm at work at da
everyone's got like Stack Overflow or
Google open on one of their monitors
like it's just that's how we roll that's
how you write code so don't think that
it's some weird thing that you
you just don't know what you're doing if
you're using those resources they're
there for you to use books as well a
fantastic at like in the description of
most of my videos I usually leave a few
Amazon links to books that I really like
so check those out if you haven't
already but in general books are a
really good resource because they're
written by authors who more often than
not know what they're talking about and
have a lot of experience and have put a
lot of effort into actually writing
material for a stack overflow answers
are usually just hastily written without
that much thought so don't start to
replace books with things like Stack
Overflow or Google or like github but
just use them as an additional resource
and there will help you out a lot anyway
hope you guys enjoyed this video let me
know what your thoughts let me know what
your thoughts are with the whole kind of
looking up stuff on the internet and
googling us that go well I'm pretty sure
100% of you watching this video if you
are programmers actually do use those
resources but still let me know what
your thoughts are in the comment section
below and I'll see you guys next time
you